[Música]
[Aplausos]
el gélido y solitario ártico el polo
norte este es uno de esos sitios de los
que no solemos oír hablar muy a menudo
salvo quizás cuando de tiempo en tiempo
salta alguna que otra noticia sobre el
derretimiento del hielo como
consecuencia del aumento de la
temperatura global y ojo porque más allá
de los debates y temas de corte
ambiental o climático que últimamente
tanto inunda la actualidad política y
social lo cierto es que la pérdida de
masa de hielo en el ártico puede traer
consigo importantes consecuencias
geopolíticas y económicas consecuencias
ojo mucho más grandes de lo que muchos
podrían llegar a imaginar es algo de lo
que ya os hemos hablado aquí en visual
político en diferentes ocasiones
fijaos por ejemplo en este gráfico en el
podemos ver cómo ha evolucionado la
extensión de hielo en el ártico durante
la última década y media en este caso
creo que la imagen habla por sí sola
queridos amigos amigas el ártico se está
calentando cuatro veces más rápido que
el resto del planeta y eso tiene
consecuencias desde el punto de vista
ambiental esto podría provocar un gran
cambio en la está y bioclimática al
tiempo que desde el punto de vista
económico y político este enorme cambio
podría provocar un montón de retos y
oportunidades se prevé que la temporada
libre de hielo marino en el ártico se
extienda hasta el otoño en 2022 el peak
invernal del hielo marino del ártico ha
sido el décimo más bajo registrado hasta
ahora el hielo marino del ártico alcanzó
su máxima extensión del año con 14 como
88 millones de kilómetros cuadrados el
día 25 de febrero es el décimo pico
invernal más pequeño en el registro
satelital de 44 años ahora bien porque
esto resulta algo tan trascendente bueno
pues puede provocar este cambio que las
frías e inhóspitas aguas del ártico se
conviertan en una de las regiones más
importantes del punto de vista
geopolítico en apenas unos pocos años
siendo más directo puede el ártico
llegar a convertirse en una nueva
arteria para el comercio mundial
como podéis ver en este mapa el deshielo
del ártico abre la oportunidad de
emplear durante todo el año nuevas rutas
comerciales para el transporte marítimo
de mercancías nuevas rutas que cortarían
a menos de la mitad alguno de los
trayectos marítimos más importantes que
hoy existen entre europa y asia a lo
largo del otoño y el invierno en la
actualidad estas rutas cada vez se
utilizan más a lo largo de todo el año
pero en el fondo siguen siendo
estacionales ya que en invierno la
superficie congelada del ártico se
multiplica cerrando con ello estas
autopistas del mar sin embargo esto es
algo que está cambiando poco a poco lo
que puede conllevar una transformación
total de los patrones logísticos de la
economía mundial y grandes oportunidades
para las potencias árticas
y no sólo eso como ya os hemos contado
en alguna que otra ocasión el ártico
también está lleno de recursos naturales
valiosos recursos que hasta ahora no se
han podido explotar de forma rentable
debido a sus duras condiciones al hielo
y al frío
[Música]
pero para que os hagáis una idea del
enorme tesoro que puede haber bajo estas
aguas sabed que el servicio geológico de
eeuu estima que cerca del 22 por ciento
de todo el gas y todo el petróleo del
planeta tierra se encuentran
precisamente en esta región del mundo y
hablamos de petróleo y gas pero
podríamos decir prácticamente lo mismo
de muchos minerales en otras palabras
todo un caramelito para los miembros del
selecto club del ártico eeuu canadá
islandia groenlandia noruega y por
supuesto rusia y ojo que el país que
hasta ahora ha llevado la delantera para
tomar el control no ha sido otro que
rusia durante los últimos años los
esfuerzos de moscú por incrementar su
control en la zona han sido tan grandes
que hoy por hoy casi podríamos decir que
es la potencia hegemónica en estos lares
aunque hasta ahora tampoco es que haya
tenido mucha competencia la verdad pero
espera obtener rusia por conseguir
controlar esta región y porque decimos
que hoy por hoy en la ventaja hasta qué
punto la guerra de ucrania puede cambiar
los planes de moscú qué planes tienen
los países occidentales pues bien en
este vídeo responderemos a todas estas
preguntas así que arranquemos
[Música]
pingüino de los huevos de oro
lo sabemos absolutamente todos rusia es
el país más grande del mundo una
condición que le permite contar con más
de 24 mil kilómetros de costa a lo largo
del océano ártico y las aguas del
círculo polar ártico solo superado por
canadá que tiene ni más ni menos que 162
mil kilómetros de costa ártica claro que
eso se debe sobre todo a la enorme
cantidad de islas que integran el
territorio del país en la zona sea como
sea lo cierto es que rusia tiene una
ventaja mucho más importante y es que a
través de sus aguas pasa precisamente la
que está llamada a ser la ruta marítima
más importante en el futuro es conocida
como ruta del mar del norte una ruta que
actualmente es utilizada durante algunos
meses en el verano pero que en un futuro
no muy lejano podría ser navegable
durante todo el año
[Música]
durante el invierno de finales del 21 y
principios del 22 cruzaron por esta ruta
86 tránsitos de barcos mercantes una
cantidad ínfima en relación al tráfico
total que una europa con asia pero que
supone el doble de actividad que en 2019
y 43 veces más que en el año 2007 por el
momento estas operaciones suelen
involucrar a un rompehielos que avanza
por delante del buque mercante y un dato
importante dos terceras partes de los
buques que transitan por estas aguas
fueron enormes gaseros que transportaban
gas natural licuado y también algún que
otro petrolero y esto ya desvela algo
muy pero que muy importante la ruta
podría ser clave para el transporte
energético entre rusia y los
consumidores asiáticos reduciendo con
ello además los costes de exportación a
medio y largo plazo algo fundamental
teniendo en cuenta que la guerra de
ucrania está un poco a poco
desconectando a rusia de sus clientes
occidentales
no y a ello por supuesto tenemos que
sumarle las importantísimas reservas de
gas y petróleo que pueda haber en la
zona y de momento más del 80% de los
yacimientos de petróleo y gas natural en
producción son rusos de hecho las
regiones tan importante para la economía
rusa que lo que aquí se produce
combustibles minerales capturas
pesqueras supone en torno al 20 por
ciento de todas las exportaciones del
país
[Música]
y eso eso sólo es el principio el
deshielo le permitiría a rusia
multiplicar la explotación de recursos
naturales y sobre todo controlar la ruta
marítima más prometedora entre europa y
asia lógicamente y tal y como os podéis
imaginar esto es algo que no le hace ni
pizca de gracia a las potencias
occidentales y es justo aquí donde junto
a la carrera económica nos encontramos
con la carrera militar atentos
[Música]
el telón de hielo
pensando un momento si vosotros
controlarse es una parte tan destacada
de una región tan sumamente importante
para el futuro de la economía mundial y
que además está en disputa con otras
partes estoy convencido de que apostaría
es por dedicar un montón de recursos y
esfuerzos para blindar hasta los dientes
vuestra presencia me equivoco seguro que
no pues precisamente a esa misma
conclusión llegó el líder ruso vladimir
putin prácticamente desde que se hizo
con las riendas del kremlin
en 2007 el gobierno ruso volvió a situar
al ártico como una prioridad nacional y
se puso manos a la obra tras una década
y media el ejército ruso es hoy por hoy
la fuerza que más presencia tiene en
todo el círculo polar ártico desde que
putin llegó al poder rusia ha reabierto
50 antiguos puestos militares soviéticos
que estaban clausurados y el remodelado
13 bases aéreas 10 estaciones de radar
20 puestos fronterizos y 10 estaciones
de rescate para emergencias además
también ha incorporado unidades de las
especias las fuerzas especiales rusas en
una de las brigadas aéreas
[Música]
la estrategia rusa ha dividido su
despliegue en dos flancos el oriental y
el occidental y cada una de estas
mitades tiene equipamientos desplegados
y objetivos distintos por ejemplo el
flanco oriental a pesar de ser el más
próximo a las costas de alaska es el
menos militarizado
salvo una base en la isla de brand girl
no tiene despliegues militares
importantes en el extremo oriental del
ártico en esta zona rusia se limita a
controlar el paso de buques y el tráfico
aéreo a través de radares especiales
para condiciones árticas los shop cut 2
sin embargo a medida que avanzamos hacia
el oeste la presencia militar rusa se
multiplica de hecho allí el kremlin
tiene desplegados algunos de sus equipos
más sofisticados para defender dominios
aéreos y marítimos en diversas islas y
bases por todo el extremo norte de la
rusia continental o al menos eso se
supone porque vamos visto lo visto ya es
difícil fiarse de la capacidad real de
rusia neta de corrupción informes
exagerados
sea como sea lo que sabemos es que en la
isla de kotelnik y en nóvaya zemliá
rusia cuenta con un importante blindaje
de defensas anti buque y antiaéreas como
los sistemas anti buques bastión pe y el
sistema de misiles antiaéreos pantsir s1
que es uno de los equipos más modernos
de rúsia
en esta zona además el kremlin lleva
desde el 2019 desplegando los modernos
radar resonantes en el que se cree que
ya están operativos en tres bases
árticas y que permiten mejorar con
creces la operatividad militar y la
precisión de los sistemas antiaéreos y
anti buque en nóvaya familia de hecho
rusia ha desplegado recientemente sus
baterías antiaéreas más avanzadas la
joya de la corona rusa las s 400 y por
supuesto las de 300 sus predecesoras
también están desplegadas en varias
posiciones más a lo largo de toda esta
costa
esto queridos amigos amigas es lo que la
comunidad internacional conoce como el
nuevo telón de hielo digamos que durante
los últimos años rusia ha trabajado duro
para conseguir un objetivo tener la
capacidad efectiva para desbordar
cualquier operación de la otan o eeuu en
el ártico y sobre todo tener un control
pleno sobre este territorio
[Música]
pensad que el deshielo además de
brindarle a moscú la posibilidad de
explotar enormes recursos naturales y
controlar una vía comercial fundamental
la ruta del mar del norte también le
daría al país una salida plena al mar
contrarrestando con ello el encierro con
que la otan puede castigar a rusia en el
mar báltico y precisamente por ello es
en el flanco occidental donde rusia ha
desarrollado con mucha diferencia sus
mayores esfuerzos militares de hecho su
flota del norte está estacionada en
severo morts en la península de kola a
un paso de finlandia es el contingente
más importante de la zona y no sólo
cuenta con recursos navales sino también
con equipos terrestres y aéreos como por
ejemplo 1031
con este enclave moscú quiere reproducir
algo similar a la situación del corredor
de su vázquez y los países bálticos es
decir llegado el caso pueden estrenar el
tránsito por el ártico de fuerzas
hostiles y desde luego si os fijáis en
los mensajes de moscú veréis que el
ártico está cada vez más presente
rusia alerta la otan de enfrentamientos
en el ártico dice que el acceso de
suecia y finlandia el bloque militar
liderado por eeuu empeorará la situación
no me extrañaría que putin ahora vial
ártico como otra vía para el conflicto y
una que le permitirá flexionar sus
músculos daniel silver break director
gerente de kingston consultora de
estrategia política de washington por
ahora la presencia accidental en esta
zona es bastante reducida el 'tío sam'
apenas cuenta con una base militar en
groenlandia la base de tule y su
presencia en alaska la presencia que
ahora está intentando reforzar a toda
velocidad el ejército de los eeuu en
alaska está haciendo una gran
transformación para convertirse en la
fuerza ártica del ejército el ejército
reactiva la undécima división
aerotransportada en alaska esperamos que
los miembros de la undécima división sea
maestro de su oficio en la guerra arctic
o luchando en condiciones de frío
extremo en terrenos montañosos y de gran
altitud y esperamos que desarrollen
formas innovadoras de operar en este
entorno general james mcconville jefe
del estado mayor del ejército con todo
muchos analistas apuntan a que la mejor
baza para eeuu es suministrar enormes
cantidades de armamento militar moderno
al resto de sus socios árticos es decir
inundar de armamento defensivo las
costas árticas occidentales
[Música]
en otras palabras que la guerra de
ucrania está teniendo una traducción
inmediata también en el área que rusia
consideraba como toda una prioridad la
invasión de ucrania puede no sólo
terminar impulsando la militarización de
toda esta región socavando con ello el
liderazgo ruso sino que también puede
suponer que la ruta del mar del norte no
llegue a convertirse en la autopista
marítima entre asia y europa tan
importante que estaba llamada a ser así
que si el sinsentido de la guerra de
ucrania puede hacer que rusia termine
pagando un precio muy alto incluso en el
artículo vamos un desastre total es lo
que tiene lanzarte a una ola de
aniquilación y destrucción sin ningún
sentido como mucha diferencia la
invasión de ucrania ha sido la peor
jugada llevada a cabo por putin de
momento la creciente tensión entre rusia
y occidente ya se ha cobrado su primera
víctima la investigación científica un
trabajo que hasta ahora se ha llevado a
cabo de una forma relativamente abierta
pero eso ya se ha terminado los
científicos rusos y occidentales ya no
colaboran en el ártico también el
llamado consejo ártico un foro para
supervisar conservar y prevenir
desastres en esta región del mundo ha
sido suspendido las primeras
consecuencias pero podéis creernos
cuando decimos que no serán las últimas
pero ahora llegas hasta aquí turno para
vosotros crees que el ártico se
convertirá en el próximo escenario de
confrontación con rusia conseguirá el
comercio mundial esquivar las
dificultades geopolíticas para utilizar
las rutas marítimas árticas déjanos tus
opiniones aquí abajo en los comentarios
y si te gustó este vídeo puedes darle al
botón de like suscribirte a visual
polític si aún no lo has hecho y muy
importante recuerda que también puedes
colaborar con visual polític para que
podamos seguir haciendo más y mejores
análisis apoyándonos a través de nuestro
patio tenéis el enlace aquí abajo en la
descripción y como siempre muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]